Tenemos que hacer la multiplicación 10a -3 por 5a cuadrada más 7a -1
¿Muy bien? Vamos a utilizar la ley distributiva para distribuir este trinomio en cada uno de los términos.
Vamos a estar multiplicarlo por 10a
y luego vamos a multiplicarlo por -3. Entonces ¿Qué nos queda? Multiplicando por 10a y nos queda 10a
multiplicado por 5a cuadrada más 7a -1
y a eso tenemos que restar
3 veces el trinomio, -3 por el trinomio, entonces es -3
5a cuadrada más 7a
-1 ¿Muy bien? Vamos a desarrollar y ahorita simplificamos. Entonces 10a por 5a cuadrada, 10 por 5 es
50 "a" por "a" cuadrada es a cúbica
10a por 7a 10 por 7 es 70
"a" por "a" es "a" cuadrada y luego -10a por que 10a por -1 es -10a.
Vamos con esta segunda parte
-3 por 5a cuadrada es -15 a cuadrada
-3 por 7 es -21 y aquí tenemos una "a"
y finalmente -3 por -1
menos por menos es más entonces nos da más 3 ¿Muy bien? Ya casi terminamos nada más tenemos que juntar términos similares.
Por ejemplo este de acá este 50a al cubo bueno ese no tiene ningún acompañante lo ponemos
50a al cubo, sin embargo hay 2términos con la "a" cuadrada y este de aquí
este el 70a cuadrado y el -15a cuadrada
si tenemos 70 de algo y le restamos 15 nos quedan 55 entonces, sería más
55 más 55a cuadrada. También hay 2 términos con "a" -10 y -21,
déjame tomar este color, este color de acá amarillo entonces, -10 -21 es -31a,
serían estos dos términos de aquí,
este y este
y finalmente ese 3 pues ese 3 queda solito ¿Verdad? Es la constante y nos quedó así nada más
solita, sería más 3 ¿Ok? Entonces ya simplificamos y terminamos. Esto de aquí es el resultado de la multiplicación.